buonasera a tutti sono florinda saieva e
come dicevo andrea abito a favara in
provincia di agrigento
ho 38 anni sono una persona molto felice
sono molto felice perché ho una
bellissima famiglia due bambine
fantastiche e un marito che mi ama
perché amo anche io ovviamente oggi qui
si parla di cambiamento e di futuro
un po per raccontarvi cosa mi ha spinta
essere quello che ci sono da fare quello
che abbiamo fatto
partirò da due immagini e soprattutto
raccontandovi anche un po del mio
passato
questa è una foto mia e di mio papà
quando eravamo quando io avevo poco più
di due anni dove lui mi tiene stretta
per mano e questa è un'altra foto
scattata un mese prima che lui morisse
perché mio papà mi è stato sempre vicino
da quando era piccolo a un mese prima di
morire
in questa foto lui stava malissimo ma
non ha voluto mancare ad un appuntamento
per me molto importante e perché oggi vi
parlo di mio padre perché durante questi
anni abbiamo molto riflettuto sulla
figura paterna dei genitori e sullo
stato utilizzando oggi questa metafora
tra i genitori e lo stato
ho spesso pensato che lo stato dovrebbe
essere per i propri cittadini come il
papà o la mamma per i propri figli e
quindi accompagnarla durante
accompagnare durante il percorso
aiutarla nelle difficoltà e là dove c'è
bisogno anche rimproverarlo
e oggi quando qui si parla di
cambiamento credo che sia molto
opportuno perché considerando anche che
su google nel 2013
una delle espressioni più cliccate e
cambiare decisamente vita dove quel
decisamente probabilmente racchiude
tutta l'insoddisfazione degli italiani
perché vivono in idee in contesti i
luoghi che non gli appartengono perché
non gli piacciono e quanti di noi ogni
giorno entrante al bar incontranto
l'amico il vicino dico che non sono
soddisfatti di quello che sta succedendo
però noi ci siamo stancati di questa
insoddisfazione e soprattutto che
aspettare che fossero gli altri a
cambiare la nostra vita perché io
personalmente ritengo che nel presidente
della repubblica del consiglio né della
regione possa cambiarmi la vita perché
non è in grado a 360 gradi
allora ho deciso io stessa di cambiare
la la mia vita e oggi voglio condividere
con voi alcuni pensieri che mi hanno
portato a fare quello che oggi ho fatto
delle considerazioni
io voglio bene al mio paese io farei
questa domanda a voi quanti di voi
vogliono bene all'italia
quanti sono soddisfatti e contenti e
orgogliosi di essere italiani
per certi versi lo sono per altri no
perché ritengo che il mio non sia uno
stato etico
ogni giorno vediamo e questa cosa mi fa
veramente male quando entrò al bar vedo
queste signore anziane che giocano e le
macchinette a guardare il lotto che ogni
cinque minuti
nella speranza di che cosa e io non
credo che sia giusto che lo stato faccia
questo con i propri cittadini sono più
di 3 milioni le persone che soffrono di
ludopatia e il gratta e vinci turista
per sempre milionario ma la stessa cosa
possiamo dire con le sigarette le
sigarette è vero che ognuno è libero di
scegliere se fumare o meno però io credo
che mio papà mai mi avrebbe spacciato la
droga per mantenere mia mamma con le mie
sorelle
quindi io non ritengo etico comunque che
lo stato lucri sulle sigarette e io
vorrei vivere in uno stato di cui non
avere paura
di cui essere orgogliosa ogni giorno
molti di noi
temono aprendo la cassetta delle poste
di trovare una lettera verde o una
lettera nera perché il nostro
commercialista è affatto male con dio
perché abbiamo dimenticato a pagare una
multa
io credo che questo non sia
assolutamente giusto non sia etico e io
non sono contenta del mio stato perché
non prende delle posizioni neanche a
livello internazionale perché non non
cura il nostro paese perché se ne frega
dei suoi cittadini
e perché non hanno lasciato la speranza
ai nostri giovani di poter rientrare
io sono una di quelle persone che è
andata fuori che ha visto ha imparato ha
fatto le sue esperienze
però credo che questa immagine semple
matica è vero il nostro problema non è
che i nostri giovani partono bel
problema è che sanno di non poter
tornare
allora cosa è successo a me io venivo da
un'esperienza fuori ho avuto la fortuna
di poter girare perché mio padre ha
fatto tanti sacrifici
noi siamo sei sorelle e vi assicuro che
loro hanno lavorato tanto per i propri
figli e onestamente e quando dovevamo
scegliere dove vivere
noi abbiamo scelto di tornare di tornare
però con uno spirito diverso che non è
quello di lamentarsi
me lo spirito di chi nel suo piccolo può
fare qualcosa e vuole fare qualcosa e
quindi quando tornando da new york
vedendo altre città ci siamo resi conto
che non erano dei marziani che hanno
costruito quelle città non sono stati ma
sono stati uomini come noi con due
braccia due mani due gambe ma
soprattutto con una grande apertura
mentale è una grande voglia di fare e io
oggi voglio condividere questo
sentimento è questa esperienza con voi e
questo è stato possibile perché noi
abbiamo costruito attorno a noi una
comunità una comunità
la tv una comunità di cittadini una
comunità di giovani che ha visto
restituita la dimensione della
possibilità perché noi oggi ci dicono
che non è possibile e in parte è vero
perché basta pensare che lei l'altro
giorno tornando da nottingham c'era
questa ragazza pugliese che era la
responsabile marketing e comunicazione
di un grande centro culturale e lei con
la nostalgia diceva mi piacerebbe
tornare in italia ma forse questo non
sarà possibile perché comunque io non
sarei in grado di mantenermi e il
problema non siamo noi tante volte il
problema è il paese da cui veniamo per
che oggi in italia un giovane non si può
mantenere perché comunque lo stato
guadagna più di noi con il nostro
stipendio di quanto guadagniamo noi
stessi basta pensare a livello di tasse
che paghiamo ma noi non ci arrendiamo e
quindi costruiamo una comunità una
comunità che è fatta di tante persone è
comunque di persone diverse e dove
questo posto non è diventato un posto
perché solo bello perché questa è una
trasformazione
ma la vera trasformazione è questa c'è
vedere gente dal giappone gente milanese
gente locale vari studenti che lavorano
attorno a questo progetto è proprio
perché cerchiamo e crediamo che il
cambiamento possa avvenire attraverso un
processo che quello su cui puntiamo
abbiamo sposato e vogliamo realizzare un
nostro grande sogno un posto per i
bambini interamente dedicata a loro
perché prima di noi qualcuno ha capito
che l'educazione è l'arma più potente
per cambiare il mondo
vogliamo creare un luogo dove i bambini
possano divertirsi dove possano essere
educati al bello dove possono
condividere perché la forza del del
progetto e la condivisione
noi siamo tornati a favara condividendo
i nostri sogni condividendo le nostre
esperienze condividendo le nostre
passioni e anche i nostri soldi perché
oggi non serve avere una casa in più di
cui poi non potrà goderne e la nostra
vita è a un tempo limitato
purtroppo per fortuna non vivremo per
sempre e quindi dobbiamo fare del nostro
tempo anche tesoro e capire che nessun
altro cambierà la nostra vita e cambierà
le nostre condizioni e quindi l'invito
che vi faccio oggi a voi qui è quello di
guardarvi intorno e capire quello che
voi potete cambiare la traccia che
potete o che volete lasciare non
aspettate che siano gli altri a cambiare
il vostro destino
uscendo da qua io sono sicuro che ognuno
di voi può fare qualcosa
questa è una frase di di bill tajkov che
è il fondatore di the cool hunter è che
una frase che a me sta molto cara cioè
non aspettare il momento perfetto per
fare quello che tu vuoi fare ma fallo
ora uscendo di qua pensando guardandovi
attorno e se state aspettando un segnale
il momento giusto eccolo
grazie